>> I'M JUST GOING TO POINT OUT
THAT YOU ARE WEARING THE RED
POPPY.
IT'S THE ANNUAL SYMBOL OF
ARMISTICE DAY.
AT THE END OF THE WAR THAT THE
BRITISH AND COMMONWEALTH TROOPS
--
THEY CELEBRATE AND THEY
COMMEMORATE.
SO IT'S AN IMPORTANT MOMENT
RIGHT NOW.
ALL THESE YEARS SINCE THE END
OF THE TWO WORLD WARS IN
EUROPE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT KHERSON AND
LET ME ASK YOU BOTH WHAT YOU
MAKE OF THIS SLOW BUT SOMEWHAT
METHODICAL ACTIVITY IN AND
AROUND KHERSON.
ADMIRAL MULLEN, CAN I ASK YOU
WHAT YOU THINK IS GOING ON
THERE IN TERMS OF WHAT WE HEAR
THE RUSSIANS SAY THAT ASKING OR
TELLING CITIZENS AND CIVILIANS
TO MOVE OUT.
THEY SAY, ALICIA CREWS ARE
POINTING OUT, THAT THEY'RE NOW
DUG IN SEVERAL LAYERS DEEP.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ONE CAN
EXPECT?
>> CHRISTIANE, SEVERAL MONTHS
AGO, ALL OF US WERE TALKING
ABOUT GETTING TO SOME VERSION
OF A STALEMATE.
CERTAINLY THAT WAS AS WINTER
APPROACHED.
I HAD SEVERAL PEOPLE TELL ME IN
SEPTEMBER THAT WINTER HAD
ALREADY ARRIVED FROM THE
FIGHTING STANDPOINT AND THAT
CLEARLY HAS NOT BEEN THE CASE.
THE UKRAINIANS CONTINUE TO MAKE
PROGRESS.
BUT LITERALLY SINCE KYIV, THE
LINES OF COMMUNICATION, THE
LOGISTICS CHALLENGE.
THE BATTLEFIELD CHALLENGE HAS
JUST --
THEY'VE BEEN EXTENDED.
AND SO THE FURTHER EAST THAT
THE UKRAINIANS GO, I THINK THE
TOUGHER THE FIGHT.
AND CERTAINLY KURSON AS THE
REGIONAL CAPITAL WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT.
NOT JUST PHYSICALLY SIGNIFICANT
BUT I THINK REALLY SIGNIFICANT
AS TO THE EVENTUAL OUTCOME.
I THINK THE MORE UKRAINE
REACHES TO THE EAST.
THE TOUGH FOR THE FIGHT IS
GOING TO BE.
MUCH LESS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
WINTER WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY NOW
SETTING IN.
I THINK WE CAN EXPECT A VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT BATTLE.
TO COME AND IN --
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS AND MONTHS
WITH KHERSON AND VERY MUCH IN
THE MIDDLE OF IT.
>> GENERAL, WHAT IS THE VALUE,
THE STRATEGIC VALUE OF KHERSON.
APART FROM THE FACT THAT THE
RUSSIANS TOOK IT PRACTICALLY ON
DAY ONE.
IT'S THE ONLY MAJOR CITY THAT
THEY'VE TAKEN.
AND THEY'RE DESPERATE TO HOLD
ON TO IT.
ITS POSITION IS CRUCIAL FOR
BOTH SIDES.
>> EXACTLY THAT.
IT'S --
LOSING KHERSON WOULD BE A
HUMILIATION FOR PUTIN.
BUT THE KHERSON IS THE KEY TO
THE BLACK SEA COASTLINE.
AND IF THE UKRAINIANS REGAIN
KHERSON, THEN THE RUSSIANS ARE
GOING TO BE PUSHED BACK TO THE
WEST INTO THE EASTERN SIDE OF
THE DNIPRO.
AND THAT GIVES UKRAINE ACCESS
AGAIN TO THE BLACK SEA.
THAT MEANS THAT THEY'RE NOT
JUST DEPENDENT ON ODESSA TO GET
THERE OR GRAIN, THEY'RE STEEL
OUT TO THE REST OF THE WORLD
THEY CAN USE OTHER PORTS AS
WELL.
KHERSON IS OF STRATEGIC
IMPORTANCE.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU BOTH
BECAUSE WHAT WE SEEM TO HAVE
SEEN IS A SUBTLE AND NOT SO
SUBTLE SHIFT IN THE BALANCE OF
ARTILLERY POWER.
MAYBE NOT PHYSICAL NUMBERS IN
TERMS OF MAN BUT CERTAINLY IN
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF WHAT THE
UKRAINIANS ARE USING.
THANKS TO ALL THE NATO
EQUIPMENT THAT IS COMING IN.
IT WAS REPORTED IN ONE OF THE
NEWSPAPERS THAT A UKRAINIAN
COMMANDER ON THE GROUND
BASICALLY SAID THAT IF THE
RUSSIANS, AS SORT OF
ILL-EQUIPPED AS THEY ARE RIGHT
NOW, HANG ON TO KHERSON.
IT COULD BE THEIR STALINGRAD.
I JUST WONDERED ADMIRAL MULLEN
WHAT YOU MAKE OF HOW THE
UKRAINIANS ARE USING ALL OF
THIS NEW KIT THAT IS COMING IN.
AND WHAT MORE DO YOU THINK THEY
NEED?
>> I THINK THEY'VE BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY IN TERMS OF THEIR
ABILITY TO RESPOND.
I WAS VERY HAPPY TO SEE
REPORTED PUBLICLY IN THE LAST
DAY OR TWO THAT THE AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS, I THINK ONE FROM THE
U.S. AND ONE FROM SPAIN, HAVE A
ARRIVED.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT AN
INSIGNIFICANT THREAT AS WELL.
AND SUPPORTING THEM IN THAT
REGARD.
IN ADDITION TO THE SYSTEMS THAT
WE'VE PROVIDED THUS FAR.
PLUS THE INTELLIGENCE SHARING
THAT WE CLEARLY HAVE PROVIDED.
I THINK IN A WAY, IT GETS THIS
BLACK SEA ISSUE.
I THINK IF PUTIN LOSES CONTROL
OF THE BLACK SEA, YOU CAN
ALMOST SAY THAT HE'S LOST THE
WAR.
IT IS ONE OF THE REASONS HE
TOOK CRIMEA ORIGINALLY SO THAT
HE WASN'T GOING TO LOSE HIS
FLEET CAPABILITIES.
NAVY FLEET CAPABILITY.
I THINK WE DO, AS IT GETS
HARDER AND HARDER FINANCIALLY
FOR MANY COUNTRIES TO SUPPORT.
I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO KEEP IN
MIND HOW VITAL THAT THE LANE IS
TO SUPPORT THE FOOD ISSUES THAT
ARE THROUGHOUT THE GLOBE RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE OF THIS WAR.
THERE ARE MANY COUNTRIES THAT
WERE ON EDGE BEFORE THE WAR
STARTED IN TERMS OF FOOD
INSECURITY AND THAT HAS BEEN
BADLY EXACERBATED.
IN A WAY, IT REALLY IS KHERSON
HAS THE POSSIBILITY OF BEING A
REAL STANDOFF POSITION AT THAT
CAN TURN THE OUTCOME OF THIS
WAR ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
THEN LASTLY, AS IT TURNS
AGAINST --
CONTINUES TO TURN AGAINST PUTIN.
MY BIGGEST WORRY IS THAT
SOMEHOW BEING DESPERATE AND
LOSING, HE'LL TURN TO THE USE
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
WHICH I THINK CHANGES
EVERYTHING.
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT AS BEST
WE CAN HOW THAT COULD NEVER
HAPPEN.
AND THAT'S A VERY COMPLEX AND
DIFFICULT TASK AS WELL.
>> I'M GOING TO GET TO THAT IN
A MOMENT BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT
IS THE BIG THING THAT WORRIES
AND SCARES EVERYBODY.
BUT LET ME JUST ASK YOU.
YOU ARE AN ADMIRAL.
YOU UNDERSTAND BETTER THAN ANY
OF US THE SEA, THE WAR ON THE
SEA AND THE LAWS OF THE SEA.
YOU SAW THAT THE UKRAINIANS ARE
USED TO SUICIDE DRONES AGAINST
PARTS OF THAT FLEET THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
--
IN CRIMEA.
HOW IMPORTANT IS THAT AND THEN
GIVEN WHAT YOU JUST SAID ABOUT
THE VITAL NATURE OF THAT WHOLE
COASTLINE FOR RUSSIA.
WHAT MORE DAMAGE DO YOU THINK
THE UKRAINIANS COULD DO THERE?
>> AS I UNDERSTAND IT, I THINK
THE RUSSIANS AND MOVE THEIR
FLEET BASICALLY OUT OF RANGE.
CERTAINLY OF THE KIND OF
MICHELIN WHERE THE --
IF I LOOK AT THAT AND I LOOK AT
THE RECENT ACTION WITH RESPECT
TO THE UKRAINIANS IMPACTING.
I'D SAY THE RUSSIAN FLEET IS
PRETTY VULNERABLE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY COULD
HOLD UP VERY WELL IN A KIND OF
CONFLICT.
IT'S ALMOST --
IT'S AN ASYMMETRIC
VULNERABILITY.
I WOULD EXPECT THE UKRAINIANS
TO CONTINUE OR CERTAINLY TO
SUPPORT THAT.
OBVIOUSLY, THE RUSSIANS WILL
USE THAT FLEET AS MUCH AS THEY
CAN TO CONTROL BOTH ACCESS AND
TRADE IN AND OUT OF THE BLACK
SEA.
AND CERTAINLY IMPACTING THAT IN
WAYS WHERE THEY CAN'T DO THAT
WOULD HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON THE
OUTCOME OF THE WAR AS WELL.
>> IN GENERAL SHIRREFF, IN
TERMS OF THE AIR DEFENSES THAT
THEY'RE GETTING, AS ADMIRAL
MULLEN SAID, I SPOKE TO TWO
SENIOR U.S. SENATORS HERE JUST
AT THE END OF LAST WEEK.
THE --
OTHER SORT OF UPGRADED AIR
DEFENSE SYSTEMS WHICH ARE
BEGINNING TO COME IN NOW ARE
OBVIOUSLY A VITAL NEED TO THE
ATTACK ON THE CITIES CLEARLY.
WHAT DO YOU --
HOW DO YOU SEE THE LAY OF THE
LAND AND WHETHER THE UKRAINIANS
CAN ACTUALLY CONVERT THEIR
CURRENT ARTILLERY SORT OF
ADVANTAGE IF YOU LIKE INTO MORE
VICTORIES IN THAT PART OF THE
COUNTRY?
>> THE UKRAINIANS HAVE GIVEN US
A MASTER CLASS IN OPERATION
DESIGN A CAMPAIGN PLANNING IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT.
PARTICULARLY WITH SPECTACULAR
SUCCESSES EAST OF KHARKIV AND
IN THE DONBAS EARLIER, LAST
MONTH IN THE MONTH BEFORE LAST.
WE'RE GETTING INTO --
THE WEATHER IS BAD.
YOU'LL BE WITNESSING FIRSTHAND
NOW.
THE MUD MAKES IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT.
HENCE THE SLOWING DOWN AND ALSO
DOWN A CURSE, ON THE GROUND
MAKES IT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TO
MOVE.
HENCE THE SLOW BUT STEADY
SUCCESSES.
I THINK ALSO, WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IS VERY CLEVER USE OF THE
LONG-RANGE PERSON MISSILES,
ARTILLERY THAT THEY'VE BEEN
GIFTED.
THEY'VE INTEGRATED THAT VERY
SUCCESSFULLY INTO THE WAY THEY
OPERATE.
I THINK THE --
CREW MUST BE AIR DEFENSE.
SO WE'VE GOT TO KEEP UP THE
PRESSURE.
AS WELL AS THE OFFENSIVE
NUCLEAR CAPABILITY.
I THINK THE REQUIREMENT FOR AIR
DEFENSES PARAMOUNT GIVEN THE
POUNDING THAT UKRAINIAN CITIES
AND ENERGY POWER SUPPLIES ARE
TAKING.
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY
LONG COLD WINTER ON WE GIVE
THEM THE MEANS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES MORE EFFECTIVELY.
ALL THAT, I THINK, CAN BE TAKEN
TOGETHER.
GIVEN THE WAY THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE OPERATED.
AS WELL AS THE WAY THE RUSSIANS
WE HAVEN'T REALLY TALKED ABOUT
THEM.
POINTS TO ME TO ULTIMATELY TO
UKRAINIANS ACHIEVING THEIR
MILITARY OBJECTIVES.
BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO BE QUICK.
IT'LL RUN ON THROUGH THIS
WINTER.
WE'RE LIKELY TO SEE SOME GAINS
COMING UP.
A WORD ABOUT THE RUSSIANS.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE DEMONSTRATED
HOW AWESOMELY THAT ARE FRANKLY
THEY HAVE BEEN.
WE ALL EXPECTED THEM TO BE MUCH
BETTER THAN THAT.
THEY'VE COLLAPSE IN MANY CASES
NOW IN EAST OF KHERSON.
THERE ARE REPORTS OF SOME QUITE
AFFECTIVE RUSSIAN UNITS.
AND I DON'T THINK WE'RE LIKELY
TO SEE THE SORT OF SPECTACULAR
COLLAPSE THAT WE SAW ON
SEPTEMBER.
NEVERTHELESS, MY SENSE OF THE
RUSSIANS ARE ON THE BACK FOOT.
UKRAINIAN MORALE IS HIGH AS A
KITE.
WHEREAS THE RUSSIANS ARE NOT --
THE MORALE AS POORER.
THEY'VE GOT REAL PROBLEMS WITH
THEIR MOBILIZED FORCES.
LARGE NUMBERS OF WHOM HAVE BEEN
PUT INTO THE FIGHT WITH MINIMAL
TRAINING.
AND ARE BEING SLAUGHTERED AND
BEING KILLED OR EVEN TAKEN
PRISONER.
THAT MESSAGE IS GOING GET
THROUGH.
WHO WANTS TO DIE FOR PUTIN IN A
FOREIGN LAND.
WIND THEY DON'T NEED TO.
AND I THINK THE UKRAINIANS WILL
CAPITALIZE ON THAT AND I THINK
WE SHOULD SEE MORE GAINS FROM
THE UKRAINIANS.
IT WON'T NECESSARILY BE AS
SPECTACULAR AS THOSE WE SAW
LAST MONTH OR THE MONTH BEFORE.